مشاهدينا الكرام يوم عنيف في السودان بدا
منذ ساعات صباح هذا اليوم وتحديدا منذ
الساعه التاسعه بالتوقيت المحلي العاشره
بتوقيت مكه المكرمه العمليه العسكريه التي
نفذت نفذتها قوات دعم السريع بدات من
مدينه مروي هذه مدينه مروي الى الشمال من
الخرطوم ونحن نتحدث تقريبا عن 330 كيلومتر
شمال مدينه الخرطوم العاصمه حوالي خمس
ساعات في السياره بين الخرطوم ومروي لماذا
مروي انا مروي تحتوي على قواعد او قاعده
مهمه للجيش السوداني هي قاعده قاعده جويه
للجيش السوداني وايضا فيما روي هناك قوات
مصريه في هذه القاعده ولكن لا يوجد قاعده
عسكريه مصريه وانما قوات مصريه تجري
مناورات عسكريه مع الجيش السوداني بين
الفينه والاخرى قوات الدعم السريع تعتبر
ان الجيش المصري او القوات المصريه
الموجوده في مروي قوات احتلال وفق تعبير
بعض قاده الدعم السريع وبالتالي هجمت قوات
الدعم السريعه على مروي نفذت عمليه عمليه
عسكريه فيما روي وسيطره على مطار مروي
وحسب الاعلانات الرسميه من الدعم السريع
فان الدعم السريع السيطره على المدينه
بالكامل وسيطر على المطار رغم ان قوات
الجيش قالت بانها استعادت السيطره على
مطار مروي ايضا في الوقت نفسه شنت القوات
الدعم السريع عمليه عسكريه باتجاه مدينه
الخرطوم طبعا عندما نتحدث عن قوات الدعم
السريع نتحدث عن قوات موجوده في كل
الاراضي السودانيه ولكنها بدات هذه
العمليه من وراوي وايضا كان هناك اقتتال
في بالاضافه الى مروي كان هناك قتال في
الخرطوم وقتال في الابيض الى الجنوب وقتال
في دارفور بطبيعه الحال هذه الاربع مناطق
الرئيسيه التي شهدت قتالا عنيفا خلال
الساعات القليله الماضيه منذ ساعات صباح
هذا اليوم اذا ما انتقلنا الى العاصمه
الخرطوم الذي يسيطر على العصر بطبيعه
الحال سيحسم المعركه رغم هذا حتى هذه
اللحظه القتال يدور في الخرطوم في هذه
المنطقه المنطقه الرئيسيه التي تضم
معسكرات او تضم المقر الرئيسيه هذا المربع
حوالي 20 كيلومتر مربع سنتحدث عنه لاحقا
والنقطه المهمه الاخرى هي مدينه ام درمان
في العاصمه الخرطوم اندرمان اهميتها بانها
تحتوي على مقر التلفزيون او استوديوهات
التلفزيون السوداني وبطبيعه الحال اذا ما
استطاع احد السيطره على التلفزيون فانه
سيعلن بياناته لكن حتى هذه اللحظه اللافته
النظر ان خلال الساعات القليله الماضيه بث
على التلفزيون السوداني مقطع فيديو لاحد
الصحفيين او المذيعين في التلفزيون
السوداني وبعد ذلك انقطع البث ولكن حتى
هذه اللحظه لم يتم بث اي بيانات رسميه لا
من الجيش ولا من قوات دعم السريع هذا يؤشر
على انه لا يريد احد ان يبث اي بيانات
رسميه على التلفزيون الرسمي السوداني حتى
هذه اللحظه رغم انه القتال عنيف حتى هذه
اللحظه في مدينه ام درمان في محيط
التلفزيون ولكن دون سيطره اي طرف او حسم
المعركه في ام درمان اذا ما دخلنا اكثر
الى العاصمه الخرطوم فهذا هو المربع
الرئيسي الذي نتحدث عنه من النيل الى
المطار الى جنوب هذه المنطقه كلها نتحدث
تقريبا عن حوالي 16 كيلومتر مربع قوات
الدعم السريع قالت بانها سيطرت على مطار
الخرطوم اليوم وتوقفت حركه الطيران في
مطار الخرطوم اليوم تقدمت قوات الدعم
السريع كما قالت بطبيعه الحال نحو القصر
الجمهوري ونحو مقر القياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه الذي طبعا اذا ما لاحظنا المقر
العام للقياده المسلحه القوات المسلحه هذا
هو على جانب المطار وهذه طائرات عسكريه في
داخل المطار هذا هو المدرج المدني لمطار
الخرطوم وه الطائرات عسكريه وهذا مقر
القياده طبعا هناك مقر الاستخبارات وزاره
الخارجيه وزاره الداخليه ولكن النقاط
الحساسه اليوم في هذا المربع الامني المهم
كانت القصر الجمهوري وقصر الجمهوري ومقر
القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه لان القتال
الان يدور بشكل عنيف في محيط المقر
القياده القوات المسلحه ومحيط القصر
الجمهوري ومنزل رئيس قائد الجيش او رئيس
مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان حتى هذه
اللحظه لا يوجد حسم رغم ان قبل الخليه كما
سمعنا من احد القيادات من الدعم السريع
انه تمت السيطره على القصر الجمهوري وتمت
السيطره على بعض المواقع الحساسه ولكن حتى
هذا لا يوجد اي اشاره رسميه على انه تمت
السيطره او حسم المعارك في المنطقه هذه
المنطقه الحساسه الذي سيحسن هذه المنطقه
سيسيطر على الامر وسيتم حسم هذا الامر
بشكل عسكري وسريع نعود الان بطبيعه الحال
الى حسن لمتابعه التفاصيل